dans l'interminable débat sur le
contrôle des armes à feu
le vermont il devenu un symbole ici la
fascination pour les armes comment
jeunes très jeunes tous les mercredis
après l'école les enfants des environs
de poker ont rendez vous au club de tir
plusieurs ont déjà une arme à la maison
le vermont n'impose pas d'âge minimum
posséder un fusil et s'il faut avoir 21
ans pour acheter de la bière à 16 ans
les adolescents ou le droit d'acheter
une arme affuble également sans le
consentement de leurs parents
je ne suis pas anti armes mais j'ai très
peu je peux le dire j'ai très peu peur
tu es de la porte m ibre n'importe où
n'importe quand